he was known to many as kojimi and he
knew the cost of standing up to
myanmar's military
journey a veteran pro-democracy activist
had already spent 15 years in prison
protesting against previous military
regimes
even though he had been found guilty on
counter terrorism charges in january few
expected the death sentence to be
carried out
when we saw this news we were very sad
actually the junta shouldn't have done
this it should not happen this is like
the junta is officially challenging the
public
another of those executed was a
prominent lawmaker who'd been an mp in
aung san tsuchi's
for democracy since 2012.
a former hip-hop artist had become the
face of a youth movement that came to
power in the first democratic elections
a decade ago
the executions are the first in myanmar
since 1989 and are thought to have taken
place at insane prison in yangon
where relatives tried to reclaim the
bodies of the dead men on monday
calls for clemency from other southeast
asian nations including a letter written
personally to junta leader minong lai by
cambodian prime minister hun sen have
clearly had little impact
this is sending a message to the myanmar
people first and foremost to try to
intimidate them but it's also
a backhanded way of uh min online
telling asean
that uh but out that they don't want uh
advice from asean
they just want asean to serve as a
shield
but protests against the military
government are unlikely to stop like
this flash mob opposing the death
sentences
rights groups estimate more than 2 000
people have been killed by the military
since the coup yet the protesters show
no sign of backing down
tony chang al jazeera